ja sehr gerne ich möchte gerne das thema
manager health mitbringen was klingt wie
ein fancy englisches wort und deshalb
denken viele das ist ein modischer
begriff und da steckt nichts hinter aber
es geht um die psychische gesundheit und
ganz besonders und die psychische
gesundheit von jungen menschen junge
menschen haben sich sehr stark
eingeschränkt in der korona premium l
täter zu schützen sie haben sich
solidarisch gezeigt habe zu hause leben
impfen lassen und was gab es zum dank
die bundesregierung hat ein image video
veröffentlicht da sah man da wurde
installiert ältere generationen wären im
krieg gewesen junge menschen müssen
einfach nur auf dem sofa liegen bleiben
tatsächlich sieht man das zeigen auch
studien zum beispiel vom uke in hamburg
junge menschen leiden sehr stark unter
der pandemie drei von vier jungen
menschen zeigen psychische probleme und
deshalb brauchen wir ganz ganz dringend
da eine politische initiative die große
kreuzung hat das komplett verschlafen
hat das als luxusproblem einfach
ignoriert und das war fahrlässig weil
das viele junge menschen im stich
gelassen hat im sondierungs passiert
damit man noch keine initiative
fermenter herr ich bin mir sicher das
muss im koalitionsvertrag enthalten sein
und deshalb fordert die ampel
koalitionspartner die möglicherweise bei
entstehen dazu auf einem mädchen hält
initiative insbesondere für junge
menschen in den koalitionsvertrag zu
schreiben ja den menschen zu helfen den
kindern den jugendlichen zu helfen die
so massiv unter der krise gelitten haben
dagegen ist wirklich ja überhaupt nichts
zu sagen es wird nur nicht in dem umfang
passieren wie sie sich wünschen weil es
leider egal ist es ist zwei jahre
relativ egal gewesen es hat sich halt
keiner darum geschert dass die schulen
so schnell wie möglich wieder geöffnet
werden dass der unterricht so gut wie
möglich in den schulen stattfinden kann
dieses problem obwohl es immer wieder in
den papieren der politik zu finden war
ist hinten runtergefallen es war
wichtiger die gaststätten zu öffnen die
klubs zu öffnen es war aber eben nicht
so wichtig den kindern den jugendlichen
das stück kindheit das stück jugend
zurück zu geben was sie in der korona
krise verloren haben das heißt die beste
initiative für dieses problem mental
health was sie so formulieren ist den
kindern und jugendlichen einfach das
leben zurück zu geben dass man ihnen
genommen hat so bitter ist es leider man
wird es nicht reparieren können die zwei
jahre die man genommen hat geben sie
ihnen das leben so schnell wie möglich
zurück das ist die einzige lösung absatz
neuer initiativen politischer
initiativen das leben muss zurückkommen
ich möchte darf dagegen natürlich geht
es vor allem darum dass junge menschen
auch wieder freiheiten haben müssen aber
ich glaube nur damit das ist ja quasi
geöffnet wird oder dass man zb wieder in
die schule gehen kann gegen psychische
probleme nicht weg sondern oft braucht
ist psychische unterstützung dieser auch
unterstütze ich nachdrücklich
schulsozialarbeiter zb schulpsychologen
da sagen sie jetzt klar aber die gibt es
ja nicht und das ist ein riesiges
problem das wird seit jahren nicht
angegangen und das ist ein skandal weil
die jungen menschen teilweise waren sie
in der ersten klasse wurden eingeschult
sind aber nämlich nur bekommen konnten
sich nicht austauschen mit anderen
jungen menschen haben sich alleine
gefühlt oder auch natürlich ältere
ältere schülerinnen und schüler und dass
die kommen jetzt wieder zurück in der
schule und im endeffekt wird das problem
einfach den lehrern überlassen dann ja
kann man sich in der pause drohen also
wir brauchen hier experten die helfen
das ist es sind große medizinische
probleme und die müssen auch ernst den
man für das als luxusproblem deklariert
oder so der ist völlig auf dem falschen
dampfer unterwegs ist ein wirklich ein
sehr sehr großes problem und deshalb
braucht da ich habe jetzt gesagt ja eine
initiative
unterstützen ich glaube dass es bei
weiteren halt nicht reicht und noch
einen satz entschuldigung wenn wir die
diskussion gleich öffnen können einsatz
ist wird neun jahre alte kinder geben
die noch nie eine unterrichtsstunde ohne
maske hatten damals übrigens ich kriege
moment ganz unter das team von phil nach
krieg und ganz viele leserbriefe dazu
dass eltern schreiben oder auch ein
schülersprecher hat mir geschrieben dass
in nrw in düsseldorf geht ja nicht mehr
die masken pflicht am platz aber das
stimmt so nicht weil die lehrer und auch
der direktor schickt weiterbelieferung
bitte die lucky maske die kinder werden
vor der klasse bloß gestellt wenn sie
keine tragen dass nur erfahrungsberichte
die mir zugeschickt wurden das
erschreckt mich aber total wenn das
stimmen sollte was die schülersprecher
und lehrer sagen was ich jetzt mal
annehmen dass sie ihre kinder unter
druck gesetzt werden trotzdem die maske
zu tragen dann kann er nicht nur die
politik die politik hat gekippt kinder
dürfen wieder ohne maske sitzen aber die
gesellschaft hat ja noch gar nicht
begriffen dass heißt dann haben wir noch
einen viel längeren weg vor uns dass
kinder ohne maske am tisch sitzen müssen
die werden sollte wirklich untereinander
von den lehrern auch dazu aufgefordert
und kinder setzen sich von anderen
kindern weg eine maske tragen das heißt
der gesellschaftliche druck ist ja auch
noch was was wir zu bekämpfen haben bis
wir wieder ohne maske die kinder am
tisch sitzen haben und ich bin ihr vater
von vier kindern ja wenn du dieses ganze
theater da in der eigenen familie
mietern ist und was da abgezogen oder
gegenüber den kindern auch in der
schweiz also das ist das ist
unverantwortlich also weiß ich auch dass
wir richtig dargelegt ich habe jetzt
einfach etwas gestand dass eine junge
liberale hier quasi nach den staatlichen
maßnahmen ruft ich wünsche mir für
deutschland er eine fdp die st wir
brauchen etwas weniger staat und wenn du
dein vertrauen darauf setzt dass eine
staatliche initiative die mentale
gesundheit der kinder in ordnung bringt
dann glaube ich also dann bewundere ich
diesen jugend und den idealismus war als
alter natürlich schon etwas eher
lebenserfahrener liberaler würde ich
sagen weniger start ist für die geistige
gesundheit sowohl der kinder wie auch
alle anderen staatsbürger durchaus zu
empfehlen von vorteil aber ich sehe die
jugend von heute sieht das noch etwas
anders aber wir können ja auch unseren
ausbildungsauftrag und werden dort
nehmen in dieser sendung
sie dann auch gegen staatliche
krankenhäuser wenn jemand sich ein bein
bricht wenn sie sagen das ist auch eine
private sache ich meine mannschaft ist
kein luxus sagt natürlich braucht
wahrscheinlich unterstützt ich würde
sagen nicht alles was hinkt ist auch ein
vergleich aber in diesem fall sinkt der
vergleich natürlich nein das ist etwas
anderes nicht wahr wie staatliche
spitäler haben müssen wir jetzt auch
noch den staat noch mehr in die schulen
bringen ich bin dabei weiß was sie
zuerst mal machen müssen ist dass der
staat aufhört die kindheit der
jugendliche der kinder zu ruinieren ich
meine masken wofür das gab was soll das
bringen kinder sie nicht die treiber der
pandemie und da haben sie völlig recht
dass hauptsächlich kinder isoliert das
hat sie auch schockiert das sind
schwierige situationen das geht bis ins
sprach verlernen hinein das sind also
ganz fest da gibt es auch studien dazu
aber da sage ich ja der staat muss sich
zurücknehmen die lehrer sind sehr
wichtig ich bin ein großer freund der
lehrer überlasst durch den lehrern
einmal die verantwortung um die kinder
hier wieder in schuss zu bringen auch
die familien oder das tier sehr
optimistisch erklärte an einem
sportlichen erfolg
der
einzige einzel bräuchte mich ja
wir haben doch schon eine eine wirkliche
verbesserung dass die kinder endlich
wieder zur schule gehen dürfen also
natürlich ist die maske einer einheit
die nicht schön ist zur schule zur
schule gehen existenz sein wird wir
haben die schulen
hätten die kinder von der schule weg
haben dürfen also jetzt reden wir schon
einen recht der schüler dass sie wieder
in die schule gehen dürfen wir reden
darüber dass wir jetzt nachdem das
wieder möglich ist kinder wie dass
kinder wieder in die schule gehen dass
unterricht mehr stattfinden wird
unterricht in der schule ist natürlich
wesentlich besser als ein suboptimaler
homeschooling unterricht ist suboptimal
war nicht funktioniert hat an vielen
stellen obwohl sich lehrer bemüht haben
eltern bemüht haben schüler bemüht haben
ist ja völlig klar und vor allen dingen
sind dass eben die kinder und von der
sprichst du ja glaub ich auch kinder die
weit in beengten verhältnissen zu hause
leben die mit vielen geschwistern leben
die sich zur vierte laptop teil müssen
die einfach ganz ganz viele start
schwierigkeiten haben und nachteile
haben in ihrem ganzen weiteren leben
letztendlich und das kommt nicht von
einer maske ganz einfach davon was sie
im heimischen nicht die möglichkeit
haben ungestört zu lernen und deshalb
bin ich der unterricht in der schule
schon besser und schulpsychologen in
jedem fall das einzige problem was ich
da sehe ich glaube wir haben einfach
nicht so schnell so viele psychologen
zur hand wird es eine sehr lange
ausbildung um jede schule psychologen
auszustatten um diese schäden die
entstanden sind auch auszubessern und
ich glaube ich finde das gut dass dieses
thema ist heute gewählt hast in anderen
ländern wird es auch viel mehr und
offener diskutiert also ich habe zwei
jahre in schweden gelebt jetzt auch noch
der korona pandemie und dort ist es ein
tägliches thema an dänemark auch aber
bei uns so dass man tisch gehört und als
nicht notwenig wie diese bemerkung
jedoch erlauben dort verbrannten
algerische
applaus von der falschen seite wenn der
spd immer unterhalb doch mit ihren staat
zu schlagen sind sie auf dem richtigen
da sie müssten
also wird